Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to SCP Containment Breach.
Now I learned something interesting and
you just saw it in that map there,
even when I'm just standing here, 17... 3..
goes and does
Whatever the hell Billy wants to do,
I mean.. 09- Oh..
096 is still there, and I'm now in the
entrance zone which is awfully nice
And so, I don't know how to use that to my advantage.
But, I think I'm going away from everyone else
[Intercom] Mobile Task Force unit "Nine Tailed Fox" has entered the facility.
[Intercom] All remaining survivors are advised to stay in an evacuation shelter...
[Intercom] ...or any other safe area, until the unit has secured the facility.
[Intercom] We'll start escorting personnel out when the escaped SCPs have been recontained.
Huh...?
Ok, so that's not good, they're in here now, oh BOY...
I don't know which direction
they're coming from but
they're not going to like me very much
if they find me.
Oh fuck..
ok... where is this? What is this?
What is this and where is this? Where is this and--? Hang on let me save, oh boy!
"After five containment breaches by 860 and the change in its UTM coordinates
We have finally convinced the O5 to send agent Izumi Junko inside 860-1. Last time the key materialized in front of someone, the re-" OOOH!
"The researcher committed suicide before we could take further actions.
Perhaps her lack of exposure to the last two exploration logs is what makes her so eager to go into that place.
I've seen them and I'd rather splatter my brains than go in there right now."
Oh...
I have the key...
I-I literally have the key, oh fuck. Oh fuck-y fuck
Oh, I can't close that door, ok hang on. Let me put this here.
Read this. Ok 860, there!
Yes, I have that!
Oooh! I have that. I don't know why I have that but I have that ok.
Put that in the thing and this
ok
"860 is used to unlock and open a door, the door does not lead to its usual
destination. Instead, it opens into a small forest clearing of an 80 cm wide footpath.
Every observation of this grove has noted the presence of blue-colored mist. So there is..."
[Quiet rumble]
Yes? "There is..."
You know what, I'm going to stop that train of thought
And I'm just gonna go in to it because I have saved and I am ready
I'm ready to go! So let us go and let us [growls] do this!
I don't know what the point of this is, I can't remember, but here we go again into the darkness.
Ho
Yeah, I remember this. I'm gonna put on my running mask
Cuz there's, so you know what I think, I think I'm gonna enjoy the sights just for a little bit
Oooohh...
This is where my best friend in the whole world
is!
Come out, come out, wherever you are!
Marki's here to find you! Oh fuck.
Ugh
Cuz I don't know if like
Just that thing is bad enough to make bad happen
Let's take the time to read this note I guess. "Something seems to have gone wrong.
The moment I entered the forest, communication with the researchers was lost.
My headset is playing soft music instead. It's very calming. The blue hue is
beautiful, and I've never felt more at ease in my life."
OH YOU TOO?!
I feel so relaxed! Look at how relaxed
I am! This is my relaxation smile.
[Groans loudly]
Oh yeah, a choice.
God, it's been so long. It's been
[Rumbling growling sounds]
Hi...
[Screams]
Hey, fucking--! You followed me in here, really? God dammit. Okay. Fuck you and fuck all of you, but not my friend in the woods!
He's my friend, and he'd never hurt me for as long as I live he would never hurt me.
[Grunts]
More choices...
Hoo boy
[Growling]
Sure, okay. You know what, sure. I don't remember there being this many branching paths before
Oh, another note, great..!
Wunderbar
"I just noticed but the path here is made of cobblestones. That is odd.
I recall it being made of dirt when I first entered the forest. I'm hearing howls in the distance, but they don't seem aggressive.
It's like they're calling to me. Warm lights shine between the trees. My headset keeps playing music"
Oh, yeah, no, I'm sure
I'm sure it's totally fun and f-happy
And friendly. Okay clearing. Oh, no, not clearing just choices again
WHAA! --Fucking-!
AAAAAaaa [Groan fades into a sigh]
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaa...
Okay, let's try this again. Shall we? And this time, DON'T turn around cuz turning around is death also
I'm going to hurry up because I seem to be
far behind.
Euugh..
[Louder growling]
Well, that's not a good sound!
Is something behind me now?
I'm totally calm by the way, by the by, I am 100% calm
Oh.
Seems a lot more malevolent than the last time I went in here.
[Growling and rumbling sounds]
Uh oh.
UH oh.
UH OH.
UH OH. UHOH.
UHOOH!!
Ohhhh!
[Creaking]
Ohh. oh, oh, okay, okay? Dead ends are bad, so I had been making the right choices
Mmm, gotta just follow the breadcrumbs.
(The sound of a Markimoo)
Everything's fine. Everything's fine
Put that in my...
Clipboard... Okay, so I gotta make the right choices or else I'm dead
Mmm
Mmm, mmm, okay, which way? Eenie meenie minie, moe..!
Mmm. Hey hey look at that! Hey! I got it.
Oh. What what oh oh?
I made it.
I made it!
Oh fuck. Hi!
[Sound of radio static]
Wha-?
No! No, no, no, no, I just-- I made it! I made it here!
Don't fuck on me like that
Buddy boy, don't-- don't-- don't you fucking dare!
[Approaching footsteps on the left]
Oh, oh fuck, oh, oh fuck..!
[Footsteps]
Oh fuck.
Uh oh.
UH oh.
UH oH.
UH-OH!
[Louder footsteps]
UH! OH!!
[Sound of another door opening]
[Footsteps]
Are you gonna open that d-
MTF: "Look, he ran away...
[Radio static and beeping]
MTF: Whatever I guess he won't matter too much"
[Loud alarm beeping sound]
[Hissing sound and sound of door opening and closing]
[Mark exhales deeply]
[Louder footsteps and beeping]
[Static, hissing and beeping]
I don't know if I'm clear, or what the hell's going on to the left there, but I was about ready to sprint--
I'm still ready to sprint into that door...
[Beeping sounds and door opening]
again
Not that I want to!
[Footsteps]
Fuck.
Oh my God...
[Loud announcement beep and alarm]
Voice on intercom: "We would like to advise all surviving personnel once again
Do not attempt to reach the exits, either find a safe area or go to one of the many
evacuation shelters inside The Facility."
[Beeping and static]
I didn't know there were evacuation shelters
I wish I would have known about that.
[Loud beeps]
Ooh noo.
Okay, I don't know what the fuck is going on over there, but I don't think they're coming over here.
[Beeping and door closing]
Fucking... what are you doing?!
Alright fine, you know what, they're making a clean sweep. I can't even see them on my list, but they've got to be
There's SCPs that are nearby
Where the fuck are THEY?
Jesus, they're right-- they're...
I'm not mistaken, right? They're right on the other side of this door and then
SCP-096 and 173 are still around here. Where the fuck does..? Oh they're gone?
[Silence]
[Click, door beeps]
[Slowly getting louder] Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, UH OH, UH OH, UH OH, UH OH, UH OH UH OH--!
[Footsteps approaching]
[Radios beeping]
[MTF chatter]
God, what the fuck is going on?! Are they there or aren't they?!
[Louder footsteps]
[Screams] Ahhh!
Fucking--! N-No, don't do it, please. I don't want to die!
[Radios beeping]
Okay...
Well, ah.. I don't under- I-I'm, I'm very confused
I'm-I'm-I'm-I'm like very...
Oh!
Oh. Oh, they have.. Oh my god
Oh, Oh my god, OMG
They got Billy
Oh, oh my God, they contained Billy!
Ohh!
Ooooh!
[Stutters]
They-- They contained Billy!
What the fuck!
I didn't even know that was possible!
Like what the-- what the fuck? Sorry to do a Jim face on you.
But just like. What the fuck? So I don't know what else they're doing, but man, they're good at their job.
Why aren't they just stationed here? All the time?
MTF: [Heavy static] "Target lost, reverting back to the original objective--"
Oh please I don't wanna, I don't wanna die. I would rather not if you could just move on!
That'd be great!
What a dick. They still got one 173 around here. I just don't know...
[Radio chatter and beeps]
Uh oh.
That was THAT door.
[Alarms beeping]
Okay
[Loud beeping to the right]
[Door opening, footsteps]
[Loud beeping]
Okay!
[Loud burst of static]
[Mark sighs deeply]
This is bad. I don't think there's any way for me to get out of here. I think I'm just kind of stuck
Oh, yeah, cuz they seem to be uh..
they're thorough, these guys, they're thorough. Okay. I THINK they may have gone
Like I'm not 100% sure. Again, I'm not 100% percent sure but I think
They're on, they're on, they're taking
SCP-173 away...
To containment. I guess
[Blows out breath]
[Approaching footsteps]
Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh!
[Footsteps continue]
OH! Hi! Hi! Hi! I give up I surrender!
[Gunshots]
Ow...
MTF: "Class-D has been terminated." (Other MTF confirm player death.)
Fucking hell, God damn it.
[Radio chatter]
Oh man!
They are good at what they do and what they do is so douche-y.
All right fine. What was even the point of going through there? Is that like the only way to go down that area?
Oh my God, that is insanity. Alright, you know what, I'm gonna try to do?
I'ma just try to sprint through as fast as I can. I know the way to go.. whoa hi. I see, okay
you're wow hi, okay. You know what? Don't have time for that.
Ain't nobody got time for that, and I certainly do not
So I know the way to go, so I'm gonna go in as soon as I can. Okay here we go there we are.
Okay, alright. So we're on the other side, so I'm just going to go for it.
I don't know where they are, but I'm going to-- Oh fuck. Oh, oh. Oh, oh fuck oh
fuck oh
Fuck oh, oh, oh fuck
[Rapid footsteps]
[Whine of static]
[Loud footsteps]
Oh, hi. No you don't see nothing. Just take-oohhh fuck. Oh I'm going for it.
Whoa, whoa!
[Yells]
"Medical bay"? That sounds great! Can I have some of that medicals? Oh...
Hello, dead people in the medical bay
I've got a syringe of of some sort. Do I need that for some ex- fucking hi?
[Soft breathing sound]
Ahhh, that's not good! Hi, HI! What the fuck?! No! I came too far for this! Whoo!
My God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh boy!
Oh boy! Close! Okay? All right? I don't like that anyway. I don't like that at all
I'm gonna go over here now real slow like because apparently I've been hit
Jesus I'm probably dead. Oh fuck. I'm dead. Fuuuuck. I'm dead.
Oh boy, that's not good
I'm going to die because I got hit by a zombie, didn't I? Didn't I? Yes, I think I did
Yepper Deppers, I better not save because otherwise I'm dead, but here's the door control
I'm going to...
[Mark blows out breath]
Fuck...
Of course.
[Loud beep over intercom]
Voice on Intercom: "We would like to advise all surviving personnel once again
Do not attempt to reach the exits, either find a safe area or go into one of the many evacuation shelters--"
Mark: Oh, hi..!
Why are you just--? You know, just shoot me. I'm... I'm gonna die anyway. Just.. just shoot-- Just-- just shoot me
Just... yeah
Any minute-- Okay, there you go.
[Radio chatter]
Wow, that is crazy.
Ohhh
Fuck, but anyway, urgh.. at least I know where the door control is now and I
I- I guess I don't have to go that way?
I don't have to go through there, so I'm going to figure more of this out in the next episode
Tthank you everybody so much for watching-- Hi, buddy, and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye
(Outro music)